there uh so this is really important i
want to talk about uh kyle right now is
basically winning on this gun charge but
the judge was not
i guess strong enough to just say get it
out because i think as a question of law
the judge literally said there is an
exemption for kyle rittenhouse it exists
and i can see it and then he goes
i'll just give the jury the instructions
on that one and it's like
you're the judge how so here's the way i
put it imagine the law says if you are
standing on the street and you cross the
street in the middle of the road without
using the crosswalk you are guilty of
jaywalking and then you're sleeping on a
bench and a cop walks over and says
you're under arrest for jay walking as a
matter of law you did not jaywalk
correct there's no there's no giving
that to a jury yeah right so in this
instance they're going with the
affirmative defense of self-defense
and when it comes to the gun charge
there is no affirmative defense of
self-defense
but there is a you can't charge someone
with a crime when they're not
subject to that law when they're
specifically carved out so that being
said
there's a provision
first the law is it like 948.60 or
whatever states uh it's titled a
person under the age of 18 carrying a
deadly weapon it says section 2a no
person under the age of 18 shall carry a
deadly weapon of course an ar-15 is a
deadly weapon and then it says in
section 3c
basically they must also not be in
compliance with these two laws these two
you know it's like 2 9 504 or something
like that long story short
it's very easy to understand
they drafted a law that said if you're
under the age of 18 you can't have a
deadly weapon
unless
here are the exceptions
if you are in violation of two different
provisions that you are uh one of the
provisions is you're hunting and the
other is you're under 16. you have to
violate both why it's actually really
simple if you are 12 years old and with
your dad
and he gives you a rifle to go hunting
and you are hunting with him
you are not violating the law
if you are 16 and you take your rifle by
yourself
and carrying it you are not in violation
of the law
if you are under the age of 16 you are
now in violation of one of the statutes
and you're not hunting you're now in
violation of both statutes now the law
applies to you that's specifically what
it says
and the judge said i agree with you the
defense
i'm just going to instruct the jury to
that regard and it's just like
then if if if you agree it specifically
says this law does not apply to you if
you are 16 or or 17 then why would the
jury even have to answer the question
which goes back to my earlier point on
the judge trusts in the system like he
wants to see the system work out he he's
coming with good faith he's believing
that the jurors are going to come not
under duress that they're going to
understand what he's saying they are
going to be able to understand his what
he's speaking about the law and then
they will be able to follow through with
it like that's this is this is the the
meta narrative of the problem that you
have here with the entire kyle
rittenhouse case is you have a judge who
is coming in good faith being
played against by both a media or
apparatus and an overtly
malicious
prosecutor oh yeah and and there's and
the question then is there is no what is
the recourse like what do you do about
that did you see uh there was a point
where i can't remember which charge it
was i think it was like second degree
reckless homicide the judge looked at
this prosecutor and said
if the jury comes back with a verdict
on that charge
and the defense objects
it'll get overturned it'll it'll get
reversed and the prosecutor is like what
and the judge was like i'm telling you
that will get reversed like you will
lose if the jury rules on that it was
crazy to hear because the judge was
basically saying
the jury might actually convict kyle
wrongly right which could happen
and then it made me realize
they had been way better off with the
bench trial but i guess they didn't know
you never know if you're going to get a
good judge or an ideologue sure in this
instance they actually got a good judge
he's just like you were saying like the
decorum the regalia he really wants to
prove america works but she can't do i
think we can actually go down another
layer in philosophy here so i'm gonna go
put on my be a philosopher hat and talk
about how we think about cultures and so
a false
what what the judge is thinking is that
both hit both the prosecution and the
defense have the same goal in mind that
justice be sought out right that both
parties both the defense and the
prosecution are coming to the court both
of them are looking at something that
they believe is called justice and they
want to see justice enacted the problem
is it's not that's not the case they
don't both have the same objective the
defense and the judge want to see
justice completed the defense believes
that or justice enacted the defense
believes that it would be just for kyle
to be acquitted on a self-defense charge
which is a very important thing if you
think that you're a human being because
what the prosecution wants and what the
what the media attached to it you know
whatever what the prosecution wants is
that if you use force even in
self-defense against our ideologues we
have the right to prosecute you
that it is not a combination of this is
not a court case this is a movie script
when stephen crowder said that this is a
landmark moment when kyle rittenhouse
was breaking down on the screen which uh
yeah that was an emotional scenario for
a lot of people do i like emotional
arguments no i'm supposed to be the
philosopher the cold calculated whatever
but the issue that comes down to this
conversation is that when kyle
rittenhouse is now on trial being
prosecuted by a prosecutor who is
overtly lying deceiving cheating
you know playing dirty at the game you
we now see that no the prosecutor and
the people who are against kyle
rittenhouse do not want to see justice
they want to see power they just want a
victory they no they just they don't
want a victory that will be a symbolic
victory for them which says ha at any
given point where we decide that
anything that you do is arbitrarily
racist we can light your city on fire we
can terrorize your civilians we can go
after your people we can colonize your
city with our neo-fascist ideology and
then if you fight back we are we see
ourselves as morally justified at
stringing you out in as much pain as
possible i was talking to a leftist
friend of mine today who said he was
hoping that the state would align on
this one and
you know basically stop the
reactionaries and i was like
what do you mean reactionary and he's
like you know the people that are trying
to to rewind civil rights and then i was
like oh you're talking about anti-fun
black lives matter and he was like no
i'm talking about kyle rittenhouse and i
was like but kyle rittenhouse was there
helping the the protesters and he was
like that's not true and i was like
there's videos of him giving medical
assistance to protesters so he's
literally helping them achieve their
goal when they're out there protesting
that that's a fact written off was
helping the rioters yeah that's true
and and i don't think it has a bearing
on a self-defense case or him as a i
think he's a i think he was he was a
good kid trying to do good because
it's it's like when you look at the you
know i'll throw it to vosh who makes the
marvel movie comparison about like the
good guy puts their gun down well the
good guy helps even the bad guys and
kyle retinos was there just to help
people be it stop fires protect
businesses and make sure people who got
hurt regardless of who they were were
being were being cared for sure all
right so i'm gonna go put some people in
a cattle car do you want to help make
sure none of them get away or you know
if i sprained my ankle you help me out
too
you know
well look the point i'm trying to make
is that kyle rittenhouse didn't go there
as a reactionary he didn't go there
someone says i have to stop black lives
matter he went there as i want to make
sure people are safe so that could be
seen as being revolutionary if he's
helping revolutionaries right the idea
that the leftists perceive this the way
they perceive kyle is it's insane they
didn't watch the trial they didn't watch
any of the videos they just think that
he's far right and hates social justice
or whatever yeah well there's also an
element of the the quote boogaloo boys
or you know people who are part of um
armed groups who are
supporters of black lives matter who
came out and said that they're here with
the protesters that they don't like the
police they don't like the government
and they want to stand with the
protesters uh but guard some private
businesses so there is an element of
this that that was there before that was
uh something that is worth considering
and not denying yeah so i i'm from
minneapolis right and i live in
minneapolis while minneapolis is going
through the great riots of 2020. so it
was a wonderful experience and what did
we see happen yes everyone took to the
streets during the day was there massive
protests yes were they
uh very large orchestrated pomp and
circumstance events perhaps you can make
your criticism whatever but when it got
dark at night people did look out they
did they wanted to look out for each
other to at least some extent and
suddenly this very broad blending of
people were some people were out in the
streets literally to cause chaos and
mayhem their whole purpose was just to
find damage burn destroy loot and you
know that is still going on in case
people keep forgetting but
the issue that happened then is you had
an entire other support element of
people that basically said here's our
solidarity because we think your motive
is correct stay off my lawn
you don't burn down my house don't
attack my my business and it got very
muddy very quickly however
there were differences in people who
were there to help and there to hurt i
actually had an idea earlier um like
somewhat in a similar vein san francisco
and the crime and they're not
prosecuting if you like steal under a
certain amount and i was like i'm gonna
open a bodega like a little corner store
every item costs 2 000
but
you get
1995
off when purchasing with a credit or
debit card that's a good idea so now
when they come in and start shoveling
everything in their bag it's like that's
50 000 worth of beans bro and he's gonna
be like it's it's just like you know a
couple ten cans of beans yeah ten twelve
well that would be like twenty five cans
of beans or no see with inflation that's
gonna happen anyway yeah yeah that'll
happen anyway and then they'll arrest
you for uh price gouging right uh that's
okay they do that in
venezuela right yeah i haven't imagined
a guy like he grabs one can of beans and
runs out i'm like that's two thousand
dollars yeah it says on it two grand
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
pm now don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you